pour le gouvernement le go la loi 96
adopté aujourd'hui est équilibré et
responsable
mais elles restent quand même
controversé vous avez entendu
l'opposition tout à l'heure jacques et
maintenant le ministre jallet barrette
alors monsieur le ministre on soir
de 24 60 alors ce que prenons les ceux
qui s'opposent la loi qui ont voté
contre parce qu'il trouve qu'elle va
trop loin à savoir sur des questions de
droit et vous est aussi muni de la
justice et par esprit l'exemple de la
clause dérogatoire pour ceux qui disent
que la charte québécoise est suspendue
pour faire valoir l'importance du
français est ce que est ce que ce sont
des arguments qui vous préoccupe
t moi j'ai vu je suis et l'expression
disposition de souveraineté
parlementaire parce que dans un le sujet
aussi important sur l'aménagement
linguistique au québec pour la
protection de la chambre française il
doit revenir aux ennemis de la nation
qui va déterminer de quelle façon va
s'exercer les règles entourant la
production en france et pour ceux qui
veulent utiliser les mots sonnent
souvent des parlementaires pour être
certain que la loi explique et surtout
qu'elle ne soit pas charcutier comme la
loi sans été charcuté successivement
pour des avis ils déclarent penser
à berry et il faut prendre des mesures
costaud pour le protéger si ce que nous
faisons notamment commune
alors je vous soumettre quelques uns des
arguments vous avez raté tout à l'heure
par son club en italie coutelas il avait
cette histoire d'imposer le français la
connaissance du français dans six mois
il ya eu des amendements proposés vous
les avez pas entendu ou écouter c'est
selon pourquoi pourquoi ne pas avoir été
plus souple sur cette question là six
mois c'est peu pour apprendre le
français
le principe de base
désormais moins 96 c'est l'exemplarité
l'état en matière d'utilisation du
français l'état québécois la seule la
mort celle de l'état c'est une français
il doit s'exprimer exclusivement
français on ne fait
on ne marche mieux pour l'état québécois
avec l'accueil les nouveaux arguments
une période de six mois d'accueil de
transition pour pouvoir inscrire les
enfants à l'école ou à se trouver un
emploi pour pouvoir leur logement mais
de voix aux québécois c'est de les
accompagner et de loisirs parce que le
plus grand défi mais la même source
relativement au déclin du français c'est
le taux de substitution les mystiques
pour les personnes immigrantes ça veut
dire qu'elle en choisit style d'utiliser
est ce que c'est le français ou
l'anglais notw actuellement d'environ
55% à l'époque la jeune française est
passée de 25 à 55 ans il faut rechercher
un trouve à 90 % nous devrons avec
francisation québec condé remplace être
en mesure de mieux accompagner ministre
et les cas sony g est un facteur
d'intégration
par les français doit acquérir en france
alors évidemment ce temps six mois donc
elle prévoit à prendre une eau claire
simon si vous déménagez ailleurs l'idée
mais la mission n'est pas d'apprendre
une autre langue en six mois parce que
l'état québécois tu es mal il donne des
services publics à des hommes des femmes
sont au québec qui ne parlent ni
français ni anglais est actuellement le
service et on va continuer de donner les
services il existe des traducteurs le
voir est excusé systématiquement
l'anglais par l'état québécois parce que
sinon le message qu'on envoie ses
objectifs de plusieurs langues
officielles non il faut vraiment mais
personne n'y en a choisi le français
c'est notre plus grand sur la question
des services de santé il ya il y aura
des contestations judiciaires j'imagine
que vous allez sur ça mais en terminant
la question des services de santé
il y en a beaucoup qui craignent qu'ils
vont être privés de pouvoir s'exprime en
anglais est ce que monsieur legault a
dit aujourd'hui peu importe leur origine
ils vont pouvoir être servis en anglais
une source a fait plus d'un an que le
projet loi rien dans le projet de loi ne
piquent les deux fois la communauté
d'expression anglaise avant projet de
1,96 les gens prisonniers en anglais
pendant l'étude du projet doit il
continuer à souiller manga et après
l'adoption du projet de rénovation
contenu transmis en anglais d'ailleurs
y'a rien n'a pas de bol 96 qu'il n'a
fait les services de santé donnés en
vertu l'article 15 de la loi sur la
santé services sociaux j'ai même des
poux à accepter un dépôt d'amendements
pour n'est
rassuré lançant des mandats comme une
ode anglophone alors malheureusement il
ya beaucoup de fausses briques avait été
dit il faut les dégorger ya des gens qui
tentent de faire peur au monde et c'est
pas vrai que les services de santé ne
seront plus donnés en langue anglaise
pour les gens qui le demandent
l'arctique est sa loi sur la santé
services sociaux ou d'erreurs se plie et
la loi 96 de change absolument rien très
bien merci beaucoup monsieur muscle
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir en fin
d'émission merci au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit